agree with the Congress member but I
don't hear an answer from the
vice-president I'm confused I asked the
vice president point-blank did he use
his power to stop those deportations he
went right around the question mr. vice
president you won't be present United
States you need to be able to answer the
tough questions I guarantee you if
you're debating Donald Trump he's not
gonna let you off the hook so did you
say those deportations were a good idea
or did you go the president say this is
a mistake we shouldn't do it which one I
was vice president I am NOT the
president I keep my recommendation in
private unlike you I expect you would go
ahead and say whatever was said
privately with him that's not what I do
what I do say to you is he moved to
fundamentally changed the system that's
what he did that's indeed but it much
more has to be done much more hostile
don't hear an accent Booker please
respond whoa a couple things first of
all mr. vice president you can't have it
both ways you invoke President Obama
more than anybody in this campaign you
can't do it when it's convenient and
then dodge it when it's not
[Applause]